mama mentality is it's a it's a way of
life it's not an attitude per se but
it's a way to live
which is just trying to get better every
single day one year after kobe bryant's
tragic passing
his mamba legacy lives on thanks to wife
vanessa bryant
the late nba star's widow defined
strength as she
paid tribute to her husband and their 13
year old daughter gianna
in front of a packed staples center one
month after they died in a helicopter
crash
along seven others in calabasas
california throughout the past year the
38 year old girl mom
hasn't shied away from expressing her
grief and through her vulnerability
she's become a beacon of strength and
hope for others coping with loss
grief is a messed up cluster of emotions
one day you're in the moment laughing
and the next day you don't feel like
being alive
find your reason to live vanessa wrote
in an instagram post
earlier this month she continued
explaining how her other three daughters
18 year old natalia four-year-old bianca
and one-year-old capri have helped her
dig deep to find her inner mamba
quote i look at my daughters and i try
to push through that feeling for them
death is guaranteed but living the rest
of the day isn't
find your reason
i tell her every day she's the strongest
woman i know and um
i'm really really proud of just how
she's handling everything and just
want to continue to be there you know as
much as i can for her as a friend she's
just
an amazing and amazing human being just
just amazing
we've watched vanessa learn to laugh
again with the help of famous friends
like
lala anthony
[Music]
it's our job as friends and family to
just continue to uplift them and pray
for them
my mom is out here hitting the ice up
sierra and russell wilson have also been
there throughout the bryant family's
time of need most recently hitting the
slopes with vanessa and her girls over
christmas it looks like a christmas
story you know and they're like
you got to pull it down what up shoddy
in august sierra paid tribute to vanessa
on instagram
calling her the mamba queen and kobe's
former lakers teammate paul gassall
and his wife catherine mcdonnell have
also been amongst the bryant family's
steadfast support system even naming
their baby daughter
vanessa's goddaughter ellie gianna in
gigi's honor a source tells e.t that
vanessa and her girls have been quote
extremely thankful for their friends and
family for their help and love
over the past year after losing kobe and
gianna
2020 has been filled with firsts for
vanessa and her girls
there have been birthdays holidays
capri's first steps
and natalya preparing to go to college
all things they've had to navigate
without kobe and gigi
and every accomplishment that he had as
an athlete
was a stepping stone to be here so
um we're incredibly proud of him
and um there's some solace in knowing
that
he was probably going to be a part of
the
2020 hall of fame class celebrating the
former nba star
being named to the 2020 hall of fame
class just another reminder of kobe's
absence
but through it all vanessa has put a
brave face and continued fighting
even while battling a lawsuit filed by
her own mother sophia lane
and her own wrongful death suit against
the owner of kobe and gigi's doomed
helicopter island express
a case which has since been moved to
federal court
against vanessa's wishes but no matter
how hard things have gotten
vanessa has continued to commemorate her
loved ones some tributes more permanent
than others like
the family tattooed the 38 year old had
inked in october
the mamba queen has also carried on her
husband's legacy through written word
playing a critical role in the
completion and publication
of his sports fantasy series ipoka the
river of sand
i remember there was one line in this
book
um that said friends come first practice
comes second
and i remember telling you there is no
way in hell
kobe would ever agree to because he used
to always tell the kids your friends
will be there
after practice our source says that
vanessa natalia
bianca and capri have gotten much
stronger over the past year
of course some days are harder than
others as their grief comes in waves
the source adds that vanessa plans to
continue to honor kobe and gianna's
legacy
and has some projects in the works to do
so she's already assumed kobe's role as
chief executive at his production
company
granity studios you can't tell somebody
the mentality that they should have you
just simply behave that way
kobe bryant may no longer be with us but
thanks to his mamba queen
the basketball icons legacy lives on
mamba out
you